if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than greta thundberg so if you
win right
come up accept your little award thank
your agent and your god
so
i have nothing against china i just hate
that their leaders are so much smarter
than our leaders 2016 we will not be the
world leader anymore we have been always
but in 2016 china becomes the great
economic leader even if mitt romney is
elected he said maybe you can turn it
around do you think he could turn it
around i think we can do you think mitt
romney can think about it i think he can
as a line of clothing now where were
these made these were made i don't know
where they were made but they were made
someplace but they're great it's ties
shirts cufflinks everything sold at
macy's and they're doing great number
one selling tie anywhere in the world
number one selling
anywhere in the world
you wouldn't wear this we also have them
in white
and beautiful where are the shirts made
bangladesh well it's good okay we employ
people in bangladesh highs where the
ties
are beautiful ties they are great the
ties are made in where china
ties are made in china
well i'll tell you and and you know what
david in all fairness i've been very
open about that and not all of them by
the way but i've been very open about
that are you okay is that you no i'm
fine i just yeah i know
the chick was made in china
you buy that at macy's by the way let's
just let's just let's just get the shut
down the donald trump factory in beijing
i would love to and and we'll put up a
thai factory in the jamaica queen i love
it and we'll make we'll make the donald
trump either so i give this little
speech like you got to get men you got
to bring the men you got to like buy the
tickets like i got i had went to indiana
jones and jaws and every movie that
steven spielberg's ever made and by the
way he's never made a movie with a
female lead
sorry steven
i don't mean to call your ass out but
it's true
the color purple thank you okay i'm
wrong
um
i want to tell you this book is uh a
crazy bestseller how many weeks have
been on the best seller six months on
the best sellers now see here's what
breaks my heart about this because in my
mind i think of you as a goon
and but then when you look at
look at this picture look at how sweet
and adorable that kid is and it breaks
my heart because i have a sweet adorable
kid like that and i think oh great what
if he too becomes a goon
you know
do you want me to respond to any of this
but as i said i don't judge people on
their cereals but certainly i do make a
very quick decision based on their first
names and there's a whole bunch of first
names that i don't like i don't like
footballers names i don't like names
after seasons of the year i don't like
geographical location names celebrity
names things like apple things like you
know tilly fizz or jolly apple whatever
they've decided to troll they're crazy
my child's called poppy
name for poppy that would be really
interestingly low other people have
criticized me for calling her poppy
because they say pop is an aunty name
geographic stuff geographic oh so
brooklyn or london your child's called
india yes but you know
that's because she's it's not related to
a location that's because india isn't
there
no we're talking about education
it's a very very lovely name for a very
lovely child
i'm not saying rob has massive teeth but
rumor has it they mark a prehistoric
burial ground
when rob got married his wife wanted to
ride a horse-drawn carriage to the
church but decided against it so as not
to confuse the photographer
do you know pythagoras theorem to the
nearest five decimal places do you
what's your favorite color do you hollow
do you know that the
snake charger that automatically plugs
into your car when you get home this
looks a little wrong
you know
is that thing going to attack me in my
sleep
uh it's well i i wouldn't
for the prototype at least i would
recommend not dropping anything when
you're near it
but do you want right now
you want the united states
to win in iraq
[Applause]
first of all i i know it's an easy
question if you if you don't want the
united states it's not easy for me
because i'm thoughtful
[Music]
you tweet very amusingly i wish you did
i mean in the middle of the commercial
break i want your viewers to know you i
mean they must know because they're
probably following you on twitter i mean
you can't even pay attention for 60
seconds
you're a terrible interviewer well you
just weren't keeping my attention well
that's my problem your is your problem
this is your show you have to pay
attention to the guests that you invited
on youtube they're interesting enough
yeah they uh listen it doesn't matter
how interesting i am you signed up for
this
well maybe that's why your job is coming
to an end
you're right
i'm sound yeah good good that's what i
think of you
really you think me a small penis
well i never
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like you have to do you have to know all
the movies is that i've watched some of
them yeah you know some of them
any clunkers anything you like you don't
like
they're good there's some good ones yeah
yeah what are you trying to get me to
say man
any clunker anyone should bet it in my
movies
that goes without saying but anything
anything
hey you did a movie too i don't i know i
i know i did a lot went straight to
audio
it is an honor to be here um in a room
full of what i consider to be the most
important people on the planet actors
they're just
they're just better than ordinary people
aren't they that's no they're
we all know that um
imagine a world without actors oh god it
doesn't bear think about imagine if they
ever went on strike oh
what would we do you couldn't replace
them you couldn't replace them with any
other profession lawyers or doctors can
you imagine a real surgeon doing what
hugh laurie does in house it would be
pathetic
it'd be all over the place we're going
where do i stand how's my american
accent what's my lines you know hugh
with the aid of coaches that can
eventually learn his lines while saving
lives he's a genius
how could you replace kiefer sutherland
in 24 i'd love to see a real
anti-terrorist agent trying to fuse a
bomb in a busy train station in one hour
some of those scenes by the way where
kiefer grabs on and beats him to a pulp
they weren't even in the script
um
the director just said keep rolling
we're working into them
but actors aren't just loved here in
hollywood they i loved the world over
because they're recognizable you can be
anywhere you could be in the third world
okay and you get a glimpse of a
hollywood star and it makes you feel
better okay you could be a little a
little child a little asian child with
no possessions and no money but you get
a you see a picture of angelina jolie
and you think
mummy oh
thank you
let's get on with it before
nbc replaced me with jay leno um
[Applause]